casi un año de guerra un nuevo
espaldarazo europeo la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula foneleygen
visitó kiev con una docena de
funcionarios del bloque además de
anunciar un apoyo prolongado al país
habló de las sanciones que han socavado
la economía de Moscú y de las que están
por venir
y hoy Rusia está pagando un alto precio
ya que nuestras sanciones están
erosionando su economía haciendo la
retroceder una generación la limitación
del precio del crudo y ya le cuesta a
Rusia unos 160 millones de euros al día
con la ley en anunció que aún falta
camino para que Ucrania sea aceptada en
la Unión Europea ya que no pueden
admitir un país en guerra y resaltó que
aún faltan medidas anticorrupción el
presidente dijo que las sanciones contra
el kremlin se han ralentizado que
anunció un plan de Putin para vengarse
del mundo libre
todos sabemos que Rusia está
concentrando sus fuerzas para un de
venganza no solo contra Ucrania sino
también contra la Europa libre y el
mundo libre para derrotar a semejante
enemigo no basta con tener éxito en el
campo de batalla
de su parte Rusia asegura se prepara
para que la conmemoración del
aniversario de la guerra en occidente no
se lleve toda la atención al tiempo que
advierte que usará todo su potencial
militar ante la entrega de nuevos y
modernos armamentos
si ahora nos estamos esforzando por
mover la artillería de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas a una distancia que
significa que no puedan amenazar
nuestros territorios entonces cuantas
más armas de largo alcance suministre
más tendrá que ser alejada del
territorio que ahora es parte de nuestro
país
el expresidente Ruso y ahora
vicepresidente del Consejo de Seguridad
dimitrimet dijo que su país aumentará de
forma significativa el suministro de
armas para 2023 con la promesa de una
victoria aplastante sobre Ucrania